all right let's talk about socialism
because that perhaps is what this is all
about that we are just watching
governments worldwide centralize power
they are centralizing power
against their free individual citizens
that seems to me
to be what the result of the virus of
kovid has done that that's the virus i'm
really worried about i'm not worried
that much about the virus that can get
people sick and of course it can
i am much more worried about the virus
of socialism
and marxism and communism that has is
going to have this elite class over
ruling over everybody else well you guys
all know nicole hannah jones she
is the creator of the 1619 project which
was the new york times
backed project where in essence the
argument of the 1619 project
is that the founding of america is not
really the values of 1776
and individual rights and freedom in the
and the constitution etc etc
it really is that the founding of the
project was 16 19
that slavery and racism are the driving
forces behind the history of america now
ironically this was done as what was
what we were told was a piece of
historical fact and actual journalism
nicole hannah joins us had to retract a
bunch of things from 1619 project and
no serious academic as far as i know is
taking any of this stuff
as fact well now there's some audio
leaking out this is nicole hannah jones
back in 2019 talking about
cuba and socialism and i'm going to link
it to what's happening of course in cuba
right now and then to some of our
wonderful progressive socialist
politicians of the day
take a listen to this is there are there
candidates right now or even just places
that you think have a viable
and sufficiently ambitious integration
agenda
and if so what is it
that laughs at a lot right yeah i mean
one let me just um
i i'm definitely not an expert on uh
race relations internationally um
and it's also hard to
look at countries that didn't have
you know large institutions of slavery
and compare them to united states
the answer is probably going to be
surprising that i'm going to give which
is
if you want to see the most equal uh
multiracial dom it's not a democracy
most equal multiracial country in our
hemisphere it would be cuba
cuba has the least inequality between
black and white people
uh any place really in the hemisphere
that
i mean the caribbean most of the
caribbean it's it's hard to count
because
the white population in a lot of those
countries is very very small their
country's
run by black folks but in places that
are truly
at least biracial countries cuba
actually has the least inequality
and that's largely due to socialism
which i'm sure no one wants to hear
cuba has the least inequality and that's
largely due to socialism which nobody
wants to hear okay so she's basically
telling you
this is two years ago now she's telling
you that she's a socialist
she almost accidentally calls cuba a
democracy she stops that and her evil
cackle
right at the beginning of something and
also the way these i don't know if that
was an npr guy or it's a national post
thing or something
but the way these interviews the way
they talk do you think that
socialism is bad and like what's up with
cuba
and like can you tell me more about that
stuff
like what's wrong with these people can
someone explain to me what what happens
i don't know if it is that you it's the
soy you're like ingesting so much soy
and next thing you know
you're talking like this and you're like
what's going on
and i can't really like think like i'm a
socialist
um anyway so she basically admits
she's a socialist there what was
interesting is she talks about cuba
having the least inequality between
black and white people so that's good
but what she's not telling you of course
is that in a socialist society
the most inequality is between the
ruling class the ruling class of cuba
right now which is doing pretty good
and the people the people that are out
on the street who are begging for
freedom right and who are running around
with american flags they've got nothing
and the ruling elite have everything
that is what always
happens in a socialist society but she
likes
that they actually like that inequality
because these
these socialists these marxists that we
have now they're for power and she knows
she's gonna be
in the ruling elite class so they're
trying to destroy
our system they're trying to destroy our
democracy and the capitalist
system and i'll get to this in just a
sec they're trying to destroy because
they know they will be at the top
of the food chain so when they're
pushing socialism they're post
they're pushing socialism for the not
for me which is what all these giant
corporations are doing right like all
these corporations that have gone woke
they want to still profit off every damn
thing there is trust me
i just went to disneyland it's a
disneyland or disney world here in uh
disneyland yeah went to disneyland and
it's like disneyland
here in in anaheim in california i've
been to the other one i've been to
disney world in florida but disneyland
it's like
they go woke as woke but you know if you
go to disneyland pretty much all they
want is your money
right they want your money they want to
sell you a bunch of plastic
[ __ ] for your kids that they know
they're never going to use
ever again while they're selling you 12
sodas
to make you fat and everything else so
these people are capitalists in their
private life
what are they what is it capitalist in
in the bed what is it in the bed and the
sheets and something you know what i'm
talking about something in the sheets
and the bed and the
yeah the point is they're [ __ ] all of
us that's the point